bonsoir nouvelle semaine pour le 7-8
l'actus sûreté des fils 78 le journal de
la rédaction pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale et ce 2 décembre il
sera question de ces syndicats
enseignants et étudiants qui se
réunissent et demande une remise à plat
des partenariats public privé qui sont à
l'origine notamment des difficultés
financières de l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines une
mobilisation conjointe avec d'autres
établissements concernés n'est pas à
exclure la verrière vient de présenter
les grandes lignes du futur quartier
gare bécane après la concertation une
phase de mise en cohérence des buts un
moment important pour une ville qui
reste stable sur le plan démographique
depuis une trentaine d'années l'unique
syndicat de la profession des
exploitants de l'école de conduite
conteste la grève des inspecteurs à
l'examen qui les pénalise ils demandent
une privatisation des épreuves une
adhérente s'expliquera sur ce plateau
dans quelques minutes à l'image du jour
la première de cette semaine c'est à
versailles au château qui organise
jusqu'au 8 décembre une semaine du
handicap
cet après-midi des adhérents des
associations comme les autres et capsa
ont profité d'une découverte privilégié
des grands appartements royaux et de la
chapelle durant les prochains jours à
suivre également une dizaine de
conférences sur les lieux cachés avec
l'aide de tablettes tactiles notamment
les professionnels de la santé seront
aussi présents avec dès mercredi une
rencontre culture santé sur le thème
l'art et la culture en faveur des
personnes malades et en situation de
handicap l'ensemble de ces activités est
gratuite
notre ambition est de montrer que ce
château qui dut d'un premier abord n'est
pas forcément accessible à tous est en
fait ouvert à tout le monde
notre ambition est également de montrer
les efforts qui sont faits pour
accueillir le plus grand monde et pour
s'ouvrir à toutes formes de handicap
plus deux dimanches par an mais pas de
dérogation permanente pour le secteur du
bricolage c'est la conclusion du rapport
de jean paul bailly l'ancien patron de
la poste qui a été remis au gouvernement
aujourd'hui un rapport très attendu
alors que le dossier du travail
dominical était peiné déchaîne les
passions pour en parler en ligne avec
nos 110 lopin bonsoir vous êtes salarié
d'une enseigne de bricolage à bois
d'arcy membres du collectif des
bricoleurs du dimanche collectif qui a
relancé justement de ce débat parmi les
préconisations de ce rapport vous
l'entendiez tout à l'heure et vous
l'avez appris ce matin à illies a pour
l'instant une mise en suspens de cette
couverture systématique le dimanche mais
vous avez réussi à obtenir des
dérogations à titre transitoire un
décret vous permettra d'ouvrir jusqu'en
2015 c'est une première victoire pour
vous alors c'est pas tout à fait une
victoire en fait c'est plus un
soulagement un soulagement d'avoir été
écoutés entendus
on voit que monsieur bailly au moins
étudiez sujet on voit que le
gouvernement a entendu nous donne quand
même un décret provisoire cependant
c'est vraiment pas une victoire puisque
ce qu'il faut attendre c'est la loi de
2014 qui sera vraiment décisionnaire sur
le sujet alors pour l'instant le rapport
va pas donc le complètement dans votre
sens justement sur cette ouverture du
dimanche puisque à priori et rejeté
l'idée de créer de nouvelles dérogations
permanentes pour le secteur du bricolage
quel est votre avis alors effectivement
nous ce qu'on demandait c'était un
décret pour secteur du bricolage et nous
ne l'avons pas obtenu cependant
il s'agit dorénavant de voir les
ententes au niveau
territorial et au niveau social donc au
niveau social nous nous avons tout ce
qui va bien parce qu'on a un salaire
majoré un deuxième jour un repos
compensateur et que c'est du volontariat
maintenant il faut voir ce que donneront
les accords territoriaux raison puisque
ce qui nous intéressait réellement
c'était l'ouverture des magasins de
bricolage un mille de france et que si
c'est si c'est ça que visent les accords
territoriaux se fera ce sera peut-être
un party game le collectif qui se basait
aussi sur l'ouverture le dimanche des
magasins d'ameublement vous disiez voilà
les magasins d'ameublement sont ouverts
nous ne sommes pas ouverts ce n'est pas
normal le rapport suggère qu'un décret
en conseil d'état exclu l'ameublement
dans un délai de six à douze mois après
la nouvelle loi soit d'ici au 1er
juillet 2015 là ce serait un retour en
arrière pour ses magasins d'ameublement
et vous n'auriez plus est cet argument
de votre côté alors en fait je passerai
c'est que les magasins d'ameublement se
retrouverait dans les mêmes conditions
que nous donc il devrait obtenir des
accords territoriaux et
les accords sociaux
derrière si on a des ces autorisations
de nous et que
vous attendez vous allez poursuivre la
mobilisation via une pétition toujours
qui à la reddition la pétition sera
toujours en cours puisque nous n'avons
qu'un décret transitoire et que
aujourd'hui on tient réellement
remercier nos clients qui ont été plus
de 300 milles d aligner nos nos
pétitions et il le fait qu'on ait ce
décret transitoire c'est quand même une
certaine reconnaissance que l'activité
bricolage est de nos jours un loisir et
voire même une passion et que et que ça
permet aux clients de s'équiper
eux-mêmes et donc du coup si vous voulez
il y aura ça pour la loi et nous on va
continuer d'être d'être présent pour
montrer qu'on veut que la loi ne soit
pas une loi mallié 2 et que ce soit pas
un peu du n'importe quoi même en termes
de concurrence que du coup on soit
complètement perdu merci sont
développées en avoir été en ligne avec
nouveau cadre législatif est attendu
courant 2014 une période de concertation
a été lancée par le premier ministre
nous poursuivons ce journal à présent
avec un nouveau projet qui commence à se
dessiner à la verrière elles les grandes
lignes du futur quartier gare beckham
ont été présentés samedi aux habitants
ils ont ensuite pu donner leur avis à
travers des ateliers de discussion et
yolaine thorez et claire cambier
première étape du projet du nouveau
quartier gare bécane à la verrière
samedi ses grands principes ont été
présentés aux habitants lors d'une
réunion de restitution avant cela la
ville a fait appel à un groupement
d'urbanistes pour l'aider à définir son
projet ils ont alors interrogé les
habitants un peu plus de 50 personnes et
une trentaine de jeunes y ont participé
on voit bien dans les attentes des
habitants qui est des choses qui peuvent
parfois paraître un peu contradictoire
mais qui sont finalement des jeux d'
inventions extraordinaires je pense pour
les urbanistes qui est à la fois
conforté des quartiers et en même temps
va créer une centralité principal un
coeur de ville un espace fédérateur où
les gens puissent se rencontrer et puis
qu'ils puissent aussi contribué vraiment
à forger une identité de ville et pas
une idée tite et simplement de
succession de quartier un des objectifs
annoncés du projet diversifier les
logements de la ville qui compte pour le
moment plus de 70 % de logements sociaux
le quartier gare bécane est aussi
présentée comme un véritable éco
quartier notre nouveau quartier ne peut
pas s'opposer aux quartiers existants il
faut qu'il arrive comme un plus et que
comme un apport pour les autres
habitants donc des nouvelles liaisons de
nouveaux emplois les nouveaux commerces
de nouveau le service des nouvelles
trajectoires d'habitation notre ville
perd des habitants régulièrement on
vient de passer sous les 6000 habitants
donc aujourd'hui on quand on perd des
habitants on perd des services on perd
des commerces ont perdu la qualité
finalement donc c'est important pour les
habitants de retrouver ce bon niveau
suite à la présentation les habitants
ont pu faire leurs premiers commentaires
sur le projet grâce à ces ateliers
discussions les avis semblent assez
partagé il n'y a pas réellement de
delhoum en fait directrice il nous parle
beaucoup des idéologistes un éco
quartier il y aura des places de parking
et c'est très beau ça va de
l'attractivité
mais je pense que c'est vraiment je suis
très sceptique les points forts que
j'aime bien c'est surtout on s'occupe
des jeunes donc ça les jeunes surtout
les jeunes en difficulté qui n'ont pas
de a les moyens de se payer des aides
des activités et
les points faibles
c'est un énorme projet gare bécane vous
rendez compte le doublement du pont au
jeu sous l'ère le la les départs sont à
salses xiii
reboucler nord-sud
ça c'est énorme il faut causer à ce
qu'on appelle le projet de la malle me
donne et la gare en elle-même la gare il
faut la en l'air et refaire si
oui ça va bouleverser que c'est
nécessaire mais moi on a dû le faire ya
longtemps
prochaine étape des ateliers de travail
seront mis en place pour les habitants
rencontre avec des urbanistes échanges
d'expériences ou encore visites de
quartiers sont au programme au mois de
janvier février
le 12 décembre c'est la date choisie par
l'intersyndicale de l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
pour appeler à manifester les syndicats
qui appellent à un plus grand soutien du
ministère alors que l'université affiche
un déficit de 4 millions d'euros
catherine mulato patrick jacques de
dixmude
professeurs étudiants personnels réunis
en assemblée générale ils parlent tous
d'une même voix alors que l'université
de versailles-saint-quentin accuse un
déficit de 4 millions d'euros le
ministère a accordé une rallonge
budgétaire allouée est ce qu mais les
économies décidées inquiète
l'intersyndicale ce qui nous fait peur
c'est devoir payer l'austérité
effectivement pendant 20 ans et que les
solutions qu'on nous propose pour
effectivement rattraper ce trou est
énorme quand même
quand on a pris connaissance assez
tardivement
revient effectivement les conditions
d'études des étudiants se traduise à
terme par des licenciements de
personnels contractuels premièrement
s'il ya eu erreur de gestion et ça c'est
évidemment ministère de le dire c'est
nous qui toujours qui pouvons le savoir
ce n'est pas une raison pour faire payer
aux étudiants et aux personnels ces
heures de gestion passée deuxièmement ce
que nous voulons dire c'est que au delà
des problèmes de gestion locale 1 de
l'université il y avait un contexte
général des screens pas la seule
université à être en déficit et ne sera
pas la seule reste en déficit ni en 2013
et ça évidemment là dessus d'un ministre
de communique beaucoup moins
l'intersyndicale met en cause les
partenariats public privé ils ont été
notamment signé dans le cadre de la
construction de l'ufr des sciences
demandons la dénonciation même pas la
mise à plat la dénonciation puisque ces
partenariats public privé sont
complètement inadaptés à la gestion du
patrimoine
immobilier public tout simplement parce
qu'il nous empêche de planifier et
d'avoir les investissements et de
redonner à la puissance publique le
libre choix de ses décisions l'ensemble
des ppp aujourd'hui sont mauvais pour
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
et nous demandons donc à ce que lance le
ministère et d'alu vs qu à sortir de son
pépé notamment de pvp donc le pp
économies d'énergie et le ppp qui
concerne le bâtiment en médecine à part
bouygues
parmi ceux qui se sont mobilisés en
faveur de ces partenariats valérie
pécresse ancien ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
l'actuel député des yvelines défend ce
type de contrat tout en pointant du
doigt le manque de formation des
gestionnaires de l'université après si
un partenariat est mal négocié si un
partenariat est mal gérée eh bien ça
peut tourner à la catastrophe
6 mais ça n'est pas l'outil lui-même
qu'il faut condamner ce qu'il faut c'est
en amont bien géré les dossiers et ça
nous remet sur la vraie question qui est
est ce qu'il y a dans l'univers c'est
versailles saint quentin suffisamment de
personnel qualifié
et suffisamment de moyens pour permettre
à l'université d'avoir les môles part de
pouvoir réaliser toutes ses ambitions et
à cette question je pense que
malheureusement la réponse aujourd'hui
et et non le président de l'université
jean luc vestiaire doit présenter son
budget à la mi décembre en attendant
l'intersyndicale appelle à manifester le
12 décembre à 10 heures devant le
rectorat à versailles
la communauté la communauté musulmane de
saint cyr l'école et de fontenay le
fleury qui réclament depuis des années
leur droit à un lieu de culte des
articles de presse récents sur le projet
ont provoqué des interrogations auprès
des citoyens des deux communes nous
avons voulu faire le point sur cette
situation avec claire cambier
sur ce terrain une mosquée devrait voir
le jour c'est en tout cas ce qu'espère
l'association des musulmans de saint cyr
l'école et fontenay-le-fleury
l'association se bat depuis maintenant
13 ans pour obtenir l'autorisation
d'édifier un lieu de culte pour le
moment les musulmans se réunissent dans
un appartement à louer par la mairie de
saint cyr dans le quartier gérard
philipe une situation que le bailleur
pourrait interrompre selon bernard de
bain le maire de ces vidéos l'année
dernière un accord tripartite entre les
musulmans et les deux mairies concernées
a été trouvé le terrain n'empièterait
pas sur le skatepark le problème il
appartient à la ville de fontenay mais
se situe sur la commune de saint cyr et
et non constructibles nous avons
rencontré les musulmans et nous leur
avons dit que nous mettrions à
disposition par un bail emphytéotique ce
terrain le jour où le plan local
d'urbanisme rentrée constructibles ce
terrain changer le pays et lui le plan
local d'urbanisme permettrait de rendre
légale la construction d'une mosquée
mais le morcellement de terrain n'étant
pas possible toute la bande de terre
appartenant à fontenilles changera de
statut si on déclare l'ensemble des
parcelles qui sont dans cette situation
constructibles c'est à ce moment-là
donner la possibilité aux propriétaires
souple au propriétaire la ville de
fontenay de faire une plus-value
gigantesque avec des possibilités de de
construction qu'elle n'a pas à l'heure
actuelle je ne rentrerai pas là dedans
pour modifier le pays et lui il attend
donc que la mairie de fontenay vendent
ou cèdent aux musulmans le terrain sur
lesquels portent l'accord tripartite
pour l'association cette annonce
contredit les anciennes prises de
position de bernard de bain le maire de
saint cyr a été clair je ne réviseraient
pas le pays lui avant les élections et
nous avons du jour que nous avons
attendu treize ans dont une année de
plus à l'est c'est pas un problème par
contre il s'est engagé s'il était réélu
à ce que la révision du pays
interviennent avant la fin de l'année
2014 afin que nous puissions nous dès la
fin de 2014 commence et déjà demandé le
permis de construire enfin que les
travaux puissent commencer la communauté
espère que les deux mairies débloqueront
la situation une fois les élections
municipales passées pour le moment la
communauté musulmane a réuni 450 mille
euros et vise le million en 2014
les syndicats d'auto-école mécontents
concernant les attributions des places
d'examen du permis de conduire les
délais sont trop longs et la grève des
inspecteurs ne va pas arranger les
choses bonsoir
laurence terrain bienvenue sur ce
plateau vous est adhérente à l'unique
l'union nationale des indépendants de la
conduite basée dans les yvelines à noisy
le roi quelle est la situation
actuellement pour passer un examen de
conduite quels sont les délais
très compliqué d'obtenir une place pour
passer son permis alors on a on a des
attributions
tous les mois deux places d'examen en
fonction de critères c'est complexe et
avec lequel il a fallu composer puisque
nous au départ on n'était pas d'accord
sur cette attribution c'est l'état qui
décide c'est l'état qui décide oui voilà
bien garé pour le zombie voilà donc donc
on a c'est en fonction d'un indice de
présence d'inspecteurs et d'une
population de référence qui nous est
imposé tous les mois d'accord le
problème c'est que dd il ya des
départements où c'est à peu près
équitable et il ya des départements
notamment le 93 actuellement où les
coefficients de présence d'inspecteurs
est très faible ça veut dire qu'ils sont
encore moins de places d'examen que nous
dans les yvelines ça devient
catastrophique puisque
aujourd'hui
les
attendait plusieurs mois pour pouvoir
passer le rdda bas actuellement oui
puisqu'on a on a on n'est pas doté d'une
place par candidat lorsque normalement
ça devrait être le cas chaque candidat
devrait au moins avoir une place ce qui
n'est pas le cas actuellement est la
goutte d'eau ce qui est un petit peu
fait déborder le vase ces derniers jours
c'est aussi cette nouvelle grève des
inspecteurs au permis de conduire ce qui
fait que sa volée complètement à
l'examen est là avec votre syndicat
notamment l'unique vous monter au
créneau pour dire qu'il faut changer le
système ben ça fait déjà un moment qu on
demande à ce que ça change il y avait
déjà eu une première en 2008 parce qu'on
avait déjà demandé ça
l'état a plié
aujourd'hui l'itc privatisée en fait
rivette vivre d'autres société qui
puisse s'en occuper bah oui parce que
actuellement
les examens sont
le monopole de l'état c'est l'état qui
décide le nombre de places qui va
attribuer deux manières
départementales et régionales
après c'est dans chaque région c'est
comme ça
et puis bah du coup ça ça bloque puisque
il suffit qu'ils aient des inspecteurs
malades en vacances soit donc les
coefficients diminue diminue diminuent
comme peau de chagrin
on nous a annoncé cette année au mois de
novembre que nous allions être touchées
par la diminution des effectifs
les fonctionnaires donc en 2014 on va
encore perdre des inspecteurs pour vous
la solution aujourd'hui ce serait de
privatiser on parle ce soir de la grogne
des auto-écoles face à cette
impossibilité de faire passer le permis
à leurs élèves et ce tout au long de
l'année on s'aimerait propres à ces
dernières semaines on a juste fait une
petite pause nous sommes nous allons
faire un micro trottoir aujourd'hui vous
réagissez toujours à l'actualité vous le
savez dans le 7-8 l'aktu à notre
question du jour le délai est il trop
long pour passer son permis de conduire
voici vos réponses vos impressions moi
j'ai eu mon permis en italie et par
rapport à l'italie la france
la france elle a délié et non pour
passer d al qods pour avoir le code et
jarry faut faut attendre à peu près à
moi à moins deux mois après une fois
qu'on a le code
il ya la conduite la conduite aussi il
ya un énorme temps pour attendre la
conduite son rôle c'est énorme dans mon
auto écoles comme elle l'a assez bon
niveau de réussite
les places sont assez
j'ai pas attendu eu énormément
énormément de temps je vais m'inscrire
normalement bientôt mais c'est vrai que
le temps de passer son permis et entre
ce qu'on a appris aux quads et tout ça
on a le temps d'oublier un peu en fait
donc voila et pour l'avoir rapidement
c'est tout une guerre ah oui c'est hyper
long enfin c'est surtout le temps
d'attenté entre une fois qu'on a fini
toutes les heures de conduite et le
moment où on parce qu'on passe le permis
enfin moi je trouve que c'est hyper je
les ai vécus et à la fin ça leur fait du
fric mais pour nous on paye et il ya un
moment où il faut que ça se calme
ceux qui souhaitent passer leur permis
de conduire sont pas forcément toujours
très compréhensif et j'imagine que dans
vos auto-écoles vous les recevez
régulièrement et vous devez expliquer à
ses élèves que baic va falloir attendre
un petit peu pour passer son permis de
conduire vous êtes en première ligne il
n'y a pas de place à l'examen et c'est
vous qui devez leur expliquer cette
situation est également une incidence
sur la situation financière de vos
entreprises de vaud auto école pour vous
par exemple sur sur but
on a
on est comme tout le monde à ont subi la
crise qu'on ait des entreprises ont même
titre que n'importe quelle entreprise
ça fait dix ans - que j'exerce c'est la
première fois que j'entends par lang
licenciements dans notre métier et là on
a vraiment bain des diminutions
d'effectifs
flagrant parce que bon on peut pas se
développer cellier puisque en tout cas
en partie au fait de ne pas pouvoir
inscrire rapidement les candidats qui
veut passer rapidement son permis c'est
pas toujours évident donc il va
suspendre où il va a retardé sa
formation donc forcément on peut pas on
peut pas développer nos activités c'est
pas possible ça touche toutes les
catégories de permis de conduire
bas ont le permis le plus le plus
sollicité en france c'est quand même le
permis voiture
mais oui les gens retardent aussi et les
formations moto par exemple je pense aux
poids lourds en forme les formations
poil au son des formations
professionnelles donc mais ce qui
concerne les examens les examens c'est
oui il ya aussi
des délais très longs et on a ce que ça
pénalise du coup les entreprises qui
souhaitent utiliser par former leurs
salariés et les gens qui veulent sortir
par exemple d'une situation délicate
pour pouvoir aller travailler oui alors
il ya une réforme qui doit intervenir
actuellement il ya cette consultation
qui est menée au conseil national de
sécurité routière se sont réunis vous
estimez que les discussions sont en
bonne voie est ce que c'est déjà ce
conseil national de sécurité routière
est légitime non pour la limite il ne me
semble pas grave nous le reconnais par
contre on a on a une institution qui
nous régit qu'il auxerre et que pour
lequel on a des élus notamment notre
président donc monsieur colombani cette
année on a faim l'année dernière on a
récupéré une place supplémentaire
auxerre et on a un pouvoir décisionnaire
et aussi un pouvoir consultatif et on ne
reconnaît que cette institution puisque
ça fait c'est notre métier quoi c'est ce
sentiment d'être entendus puisque vous
êtes mobilisés vous avez manifesté en
fin de semaine fin novembre on a été
reçus nous a promis certaines choses on
attend le douce quand date à laquelle on
doit il doit y avoir des
tas laquelle dwyer une décision
définitive
on reste mobilisé et si vous recommencez
l'opération escargot on recommencera les
opérations au cerveau merci d'être venu
sur ce plateau je rappelle que vous êtes
représentante membres de l'unique
l'union des indépendants de la conduite
merci à vous en fin de semaine dernière
la mairie de trappes en partenariat avec
la libre et le millefeuille nous en
avons parlé sur cette antenne organisé
l'opération graines de culture l'idée
troquer des livres contre des graines et
des graines contre des livres olivier
maniscalco elodie moines
comme liliane qui est venu échanger ses
livres contre des oeillets à delta ils
étaient plus d'une cinquantaine vendredi
à la librairie le millefeuille de
trappes pour participer à l'opération
graines de culture le principe est
simple sous forme de troc chacun peut
échanger soit des livres contre des
graines soient des graines contre des
livres en résumé troqué de la culture
contre de la culture 22 culture à la
base ça vient du projet des jardins
partagés donc c'est la mairie qui
envisagent de pièces depuis deux trois
ans à mettre des jardins partagés dans
la ville de trappes l'idée c'était de
donc à d'aménager ce jardin pour de la
culture et en même temps de créer un
événement culturel ouvert à tous une
fois par mois c'est un échange puis
c'est vrai que parfois quand on va dans
les magasins c'est assez cher
relativement cher et donc nos moyens
nous permettent pas toujours de pouvoir
l'acheter les plantes et voudrait si les
livres récupérer vont venir alimenter la
bibliothèque les graines et les bulbes a
mené par les participants serviront à la
culture du premier jardin partagé de la
ville de trappes un jardin de dix
emplacements basé sur le site de la
librairie et qui propose encore cinq
places disponibles avis aux amateurs
et puisque l'on parle solidarité les
père noël vers 2013 sont déjà là le
secours populaire français a lancé
officiellement cette opération qui
permet chaque année de collecter des
jouets de récolter des fonds réalisant
également les paquets cadeaux à la
sortie de vos magasins des braderies et
de noël sont aussi organisés en et vous
sur le site de l'association pour plus
de détails la fédération des yvelines
est basé sur la ville de trappes c'est
la fin de cette édition du 7 8 l'actus
je vous retrouve demain aux mêmes
horaires pour faire un point complet sur
l'actualité locale vos commentaires sur
les réseaux sociaux et puis n'oubliez
pas que pour le point complet sur le
sport c'est chaque lundi avec le 7-8
sports anthony rey je vous donne rendez
vous à 18h30 19h30 et 22h30 il reviendra
notamment cette semaine sur le titre de
champion de france des poids welters
décroché par le ver est roi ahmed el
moussaoui le jeune boxeur qui grimpe au
centquatre du 180 14e rang au 92e rang
mondial une grosse performance il en
prendra dans le prochain 7,8 sport
excellente soirée